this song is about my colon so if you
were grossed out easily by talk about
butts then you shouldn't listen to it
also it has some bad words
so pg-13 I have a complicated
relationship with the distal portion of
my large intestine also known as Michael
and I started feeling kind of shitty
when I turned 23 and in the pain got
worse and worse every day in the days
turned into weeks I finally went to see
the doctor made me poop into look up and
then a few weeks after that he shoved a
camera up my butt and the camera was in
a tube and the tube it pumped out her so
that my colon couldn't fight in they
could look around in there and when I
woke up the doctor was looking at my
chart I called his attention to me with
a 15-minute fart and he said son I hate
to tell you cuz you're probably not
gonna like this but they got a name for
what you have in it is ulcerative
colitis and in those seven syllables
there's a mess of shitty news it's
likely that you've had your last healthy
feeling booze it's like road rash on
your colon you'll bleed it'll hurt and
no one knows what causes it in there
it's no cure and yeah your chances of
cancer have gone up of it but colon
cancer is curable if you keep your eye
on it see what's really gonna piss you
off it's how much you gotta pay I know
you're not insured and you'll probably
stay that way the insurance companies
hate to deal with sick books like you
they don't like taking money from book
they might have to give it back to and
your pills are gonna cost you both of
your arms in at least one leg I suggest
you go to Canada get on your knees and
beg because here the costs are as high
as the market can bear and the can bear
a lot compared with soiled underwear i
sat there on that bed and thought about
how I used to like taboo I thought maybe
there was a mistake how could this be
true I asked the doctor pleading begging
if he was sure and if he was how good
I'd be that there was no guilty only
cure we have you said is to take the
whole thing out and then they get your
movements out we install a little spout
I told him that I'd rather take a
thousand thousand dollar bills he agreed
and sent me home with similar sounding
bills and now really what I've learned
besides the importance of fibers that
the healthcare systems more screwed up
than a 50 year old bread subscriber
[Music]
probably didn't enjoy that as much as I
did but I hope you did hi this is Hank
sock and I was wondering um Hank Hank
dude it ruins the illusion when you do
that ah I'll be down here oh sorry I was
wondering if you ever get pissed off
that John gets to answer questions all
the time and you never get to answer
questions because you don't have
questions Tuesdays come on let's look
for some questions okay I found some not
a lot but some are you gonna coat with
another album yes I will be putting out
another album I don't know when it's
going to be out though Hank what's going
on with the FT ba records dftba records
is doing very well we've just released
David Daisy's first album you know Dave
days he's got like 300,000 subscribers
or something ridiculous so you can go
buy his album at dftba.com right now
also the dftba records compilation Ava's
going on pre-order today and it will be
shipped out on June 1st
it's got charlie is so cool like Alex
day Michael Aranda Molly Lewis Julia
Nunes Alamo stuff Dave days Tom Milsom
and it has anglerfish on it and it's
also being bundled with chameleon
circuits first album chameleon circuit
being the Time Lord rock band with
charlieissocoollike an airman in it if
you're at LeakyCon you'll be able to get
this there so don't pre-order if you're
gonna go to LeakyCon because if you can
get it faster for me and this happens
everyone say the dftba radio are will be
beginning soon there's a link in the
sidebar
and what about LeakyCon I'm very excited
about LeakyCon John and I have been
working on our speech all week long if
there are nerdfighters and around Boston
who aren't gonna be at LeakyCon er they
gotta be able to hang out with you at
all anything anything for non Harry
Potter nerd fighters at all John
unfortunately will be leaving
immediately after LeakyCon but I'll be
hanging out in Boston just a little
extra and I'll be playing songs and
gathering with nerdfighters at the lily
pad from 4:00 to 5:30 p.m. on Sunday so
it turns out that I do like answering
questions so if you would like to leave
some in the comments I would answer them
later john dftba